Ich bin 174 kg groß und 80 kg schwer.
Was für eine Säge und so habe ich.
Wo sind die Tische Marzen genau?
Im Unterbauch.
Wann hat die Marzen begonnen?
Vor drei Tagen.
Die werden immer schlimmer.
Wie viele sind auf einer Säge?
Sieben.
Wie wurden sie geübt?
Wie sind sie beschrieben?
Beides drückend und stechend.
Ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht kommen.
Aber es ging nicht anders.
Ich musste jetzt kommen.
Ich habe die Schmerzmedikamente nicht gewirbt.
Deswegen bin ich hier und hoffe, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Ja, natürlich.
Geben Sie mir den Schmerzmedikament?
Sie haben schon ein Medikament angenommen.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie haben schon einmal angenommen.
Aber es wird nicht besser.
Vielleicht können Sie mir schon etwas geben, damit die Schmerzen besser sind.
Haben Sie allergängige Marzen-Mitdikamente?
Nicht bekannt.
Wenn Sie das Ende geschützt haben,
die Schmerzen aussahlen können,
können Sie uns die Diagnose sicherlich feststellen.
Aber wenn Sie nicht ertragen,
kann ich gerne ein Schmerzmittel geben.
Ich kann noch ein bisschen aushalten.
Aber ich brauche dringend ein Schmerzmedikament,
weil ich kann es nicht mehr aushalten gleich.
Ja, ich beeile mich.
Sie haben vor vier Tagen gesagt,
dass die Schmerzen angepangen sind.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder vorübergehend?
Die sind eigentlich dauerhaft.
Die werden immer schlimmer.
Ich habe noch keinen Tag gehabt, wo ich die Schmerzen nicht gehabt habe.
Ist Ihnen dafür ein Ausschlöser aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung, was sein könnte.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Angst.
Mein Schwiegervater ist ein Darungskripsverstorben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das eventuell auch so etwas sein könnte.
Wir beschwerden, können verschiedene Krankheiten verursachen.
Deswegen machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Herr Fisch, Sie haben gesagt,
wo sind die linken Seiten?
Er ist links.
Okay.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen einmal gehabt?
So stark hatte ich sie noch nie.
Das erste Mal so stark.
Aber ich habe das schon einmal gehabt.
Sie sind noch 10 Jahre alt.
Sie sind aber von alleine wieder zugegangen.
Ich habe nichts dabei gedacht, aber jetzt sind sie extrem.
Waren Sie damals behandelt worden?
Nein, ich habe damals auch Parats tamol genommen.
Das ist eigentlich auch geholfen.
Haben Sie Begleitenseptomen wie Übelkeit, Amazis?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Übelkeit.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich langsam fieberig werde.
Ich habe eine höhere Temperatur, glaube ich, aber ich habe auch nicht gemessen.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Seit gestern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Fieber ist.
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Aber ich fühle mich warm an.
Ich habe kein Fieber-Messgerät deswegen.
Ich wüssten Sie mehr?
Ich habe in den Nacht ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Auch weil ich Schmerzen gehabt habe.
Haben Sie Stifelstift?
Nein, eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Mussten Sie sich überall geben?
Nein, aber ein leichtes Übelkeitsgefühl habe ich die ganze Zeit.
Aber die Schmerzen sind im Vordergrund.
Ich habe richtig Schmerzen.
Ich habe auch Schmerzen.
Wie oft gehen Sie schütterlos zum Schüttergang?
Ich glaube gestern, ich habe es mehr als fünf oder sechs Mal.
Wie sieht aus Ihr Schütter?
Wesrig.
Haben Sie das Blut im Schütter bemerkt?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Wie ist es bei der Masse?
Haben Sie Probleme?
Nein, ein leichtes Brennen, aber es ist nicht so schlimm.
Ja, nicht so schlimm.
Ja, es ist aber nicht der Redewert, es ist wenig.
Und haben Sie sonst gewünscht, Atemnot, Herzrasen?
Nicht, habe ich nicht bemerkt, nur diese starken Schmerzen nicht aktuell habe.
Ja, haben Sie inderlässig sein und gewollte ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe jetzt aber in den letzten drei, vier Tagen wenig gegessen, deswegen habe ich bestimmt ein bisschen abgenommen.
Sie haben Appetitloskeit?
Nein, ich habe wenig gegessen, ich habe schon Appetit, aber ich habe wenig gegessen.
Deswegen habe ich bestimmt abgenommen.
Wie setzten Sie, wie leicht, wie viel Kilo haben Sie?
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Wie meinen Sie in der letzten Zeit, ein Monat, drei Monate?
Nein, in den letzten paar Tagen.
Ich habe nicht viel gegessen, habe ich schon Probleme.
Jetzt aktuell oder generell?
Generell.
Generell eigentlich habe ich keine Probleme, ich habe viel Stress, deswegen glaube ich manchmal schlecht, aber eigentlich nie immer.
Ich möchte wissen, über Ihre Gesundheit zu schütteln, sind Sie vollständig geheim?
Gemeinsam vollständig geheim?
Ja, gegen Kinderkrankheiten und gegen Corona sind Sie vollständig geheim.
Also ich habe die letzten Kontrolle bei meinem Haus, das war schon jetzt bestimmt fünf, sechs Jahre her,
hat den Checkup gemacht, hat den nichts gesagt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, vielleicht haben Sie zufällig Ihr Impfast dabei?
Leider nicht, zufällig nicht, nein.
Okay, und Sie haben keine Allergen, haben Sie Unverdrecklichkeit gegen Lebensmittel oder Medikamente?
Nicht bekannt, nicht bekannt.
Also ich habe bemerkt, dass ich ein bisschen gegen Milch und ein bisschen mit Krummel und bisschen Bauchschmerzen reagiere,
aber ich habe das noch nicht jetzt prüfen lassen.
Okay, ich hatte noch ein paar Fragen für aktuelle Bescheiden.
Sind die Bauchschmerzen mit dem Versaar verbunden?
Ich habe jetzt die letzten paar Tage wie gesagt wenig gegessen, aber ich habe jetzt nur Super getrunken und die werden immer mehr geschmerzen.
Okay, ja, Herr Kisch, haben Sie für Erkrankungen, wie Bluthochdruck, Blutsuga-Kranke?
Ja, ich habe Bluthochdruck, ich habe erhöhten Cholesterin und ich habe eine Schilddrösenunterfunktion.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ach, das ist schon länger, das ist schon, stimmt, sechs, sieben Jahre her, also vielleicht auch ein bisschen später.
Es ist zufällig festgestellt worden bei dem Checkup bei meinem Hausarzt.
Okay, was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme ein Blutdruck-Medikament, ein Cholesterinsenker und etwas gegen mich Schilddrösen.
Wie sind Sie die Namen von Medikamenten?
Ja, das ist einmal Amnodipin, mich einmal am Tag.
Wie viel Milk?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe ein Atrovastatinaist, das ist 20 Milligramm, das weiß ich.
Und einmal Ältyroxin, 25.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Seit wann?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Schilddrösenunterfunktion?
Wie gesagt, das ist vor fünf, sechs Jahren festgestellt worden bei dem Checkup bei meinem Hausarzt.
Okay.
Waren Sie schon mal stationär, irgendwelche Krankenhausbehandeln geworden?
Ich war ein paar Mal im Krankenhaus, aber ich bin, ich habe nichts Schlimmes.
Ich habe einmal, habe ich etwas am Knie gehabt, das musste kontrolliert werden, dann haben die da reingeguckt und ansonsten habe ich so nichts gehabt.
Wurdun Sie schon mal operiert?
Meine Mandeln sind raus.
Schon in der Kindheit?
Ja, aus Kindheit, okay.
Ich möchte wissen, über Ihre Lebensgewandtheiten, raufun Sie?
Ich bin Raucher.
Seit wann raufun Sie?
Das ist für lange her. Ich bin jetzt ein fünf Jahre, 30 Jahre, vielleicht länger, 35 Jahre, weil ich nicht ganz genau.
Wie viele Skritter raufun Sie täglich?
10 bis 15.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal.
Wie meinen Sie pro Monat, pro Woche?
Ab und zu und Wochenende ein bisschen.
Was für Alkohol trinken Sie?
Wein, Bier, so etwas in der Art.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht Person nicht, haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Ob ich Drogen einnehme?
Das ist eine rhythmische Frage, wir müssen diese Frage stellen.
Nein, ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Okay.
Hab ich Leben, Ehre, auch noch?
Meine Eltern sind beide verstorben.
Das tut mir leid, woran sind Sie gestorben?
Meine Mutter hat einen Schlaganfall.
Und mein Vater hat einen, man weiß nicht ganz genau, irgendeine Herzerkrankung.
Er ist früh verstorben, aber ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was es war.
Okay, kann es ein Herzinfarkt sein?
Ich weiß nicht, er hat einen Herzerkrankung.
Hatten Sie Ihre Altein noch sonstige Krankheiten wie Blutwachterung?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Krebs?
Nein, Krebs hatten die beiden nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Angehörige hat Krebs?
Ja, mein Schwiegervater.
Aber Sie haben keine arpische Verbindung mit dem Schwiegervater.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe keine Geschwester, keine Brüder, ich bin Einzelkind.
Ja, hervisch, warum sind Sie beruflich?
Ich bin ein Enginierer.
Ein Enginierer oder ein Bau-Engineer?
Ich bin ein Maschin-Bau-Engineer.
Okay, was ist Ihre Arbeit?
Ich bin ein Engineer, der in Deutschland ist.
Ein eigener Bruder?
Nein, ich bin ein Enginierer.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, bei der Arbeit.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Machen Sie supportliche Aktivitäten?
Ja, viel Fahrrad fahren.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich möchte nichts hinzufügen, ich habe Schmerzen.
Was glauben Sie, dass ich habe?
Ja, hervisch, ich war Mutter.
Sie haben Probleme mit dem Darm.
Kann das also doch Krebs sein?
Ja, das ist so früh, die Diagnose festzuschütteln,
aber Ihre Beschwerden sprechen nicht ganz für Krebs.
Aber nach der Untersuchung kann ich Ihnen die Diagnose sicher sagen.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt für Diagnose?
Ich werde die Körperlösung untersuchen.
Ich gebe Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel und ein paar Labors und Bildgebundesverfahren.
Was heißt das Bildgebundesverfahren?
Ja, eine Bauchspiegelung.
Eine Operation?
Nein, das ist nur eine Surbeiurteilung für die inneren Organen.
Eine Bauchspiegelung heißt Operation, oder?
Ich habe vielleicht etwas pro Bauch- und Ultrationalen.
Ok, dafür muss ich aber nicht in der Kurse.
Aufwärts können Sie uns ein bisschen bekommen.
Nicht bei der Bauchspiegelung, sondern die Begründung können wir durchführen.
Ach, dann müssen Sie auch machen.
Nicht jetzt.
Erst muss ich eine Infektion in den Organen auszuschliessen.
Dann muss ich hier bleiben?
Ich werde sie jetzt stationär aufnehmen.
Je nach der Ergebnisse von Untersuchungen werde ich eine Therapie einleiten.
Ich werde sie dann in die Pflege und Pflege geben.
Fürstigkeit zum Trinken?
Antibiotika.
Sie haben Übelkeit, vielleicht, dass es eine Pflegekabel durch Zugang besser ist.
Zugang?
Ja.
Wie meinen Sie Zugang?
Über einen Magenschlauch?
Nein, in den Beinen.
Ach so, mit so einer Nadel?
Ah, ok, verstanden.
Sie können mich kurz warten, ich komme Ihnen gleich.
Vielen Dank.
Ich werde Sie gleich untersuchen.
Ich habe 20 Minuten mit Ihnen gesprochen.
Das dauert nicht so lange.
In einer halben Minute bin ich wieder da.
Ok, alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Kollegin an die Frage.
Sie haben die Schmerzen in der 15. Region aus.
Nein, mittig und links im Unterbauch.
Wenn ich das Bein bewege, dann auch ein bisschen im Rücken.
Sie haben die Schmerzen langsam angefangen.
Wie gesagt, seit 3 bis 4 Tagen.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarsch.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen neuen Patienten,
den Herfisch vorstellen.
Sie haben die Kurse seitförmig.
Sie haben die Kurse seit 3 bis 4 Tagen.
Sie haben die Schmerzen nach vorne.
Es geht um Peter Harfisch.
Peter Harfisch ist 51 Jahre alt.
Eine Meter 74 courtyard als ich gelöschen war.
Edward Harfisch sagte sich bei uns vor 4 Tagen
beruflich auf getretenen Arsen nehmen,
links vor. Tarfe ist berichtet, dass er gegen Schmerzen gestern dreimal, heute zweimal,
Parastomol tablett eingenommen. Das hat aber ihm nicht geholfen.
Könnt ihr nochmal ganz kurz sagen, wo hat der Schmerzen?
Unter Bauchbordersch, links.
Links, ok.
Ok, also links, ok, dann.
Ja, Parastomol, er ist über Neusea, ohne MSI, auf Nachfrage, hat er berichtet,
er fieberisch gefühlt habe und hat er gemessen, wie war?
Nein, er hat nicht gemessen und er hat seit gestern fünfmal die Jahre und
Insgesamt oder am Tag?
Am Tag.
Also pro Tag, fünfmal?
Ja.
Und die Jahre sieht aus wästige und hat kein Blut gemischt inhalt.
Und ja, er hat bei Masalasen brennende Schmerzen.
Die Bekannung und die Anamnese, ja, Erwähnende, Inderbekannung und die Anamnese,
gab und gewollte, abgenommen, Gewichtabnahme in den letzten Tagen und trotz
Gute Appetit.
Er hat Gewichtabnahme in den letzten Tagen.
Aber ja, sie hat so erwähnt, aber sie hat nicht, er hat sein
Kilonisch gemessen.
Also kein relevantes Gewichtslust?
Ja, ich muss bei der Koalitionstersuchung den Patienten wegen, ob er abgenommen
habe.
Er ist gegen Kindheitkrankheiten oder Corona,
das war keine Aufwelligkeiten.
Es sind keine Allergen bei im Bekannt.
Und manchmal hat er ja Produkten nicht vertragen.
Er ist Rahör mit seit 30 Jahren Rahö'e, sein bis 50er-Sigaretten.
Und am Wochenende trinkt er gelegentlich Alkohol.
Und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Es sind Arteriellehypertone und Hypoterozof, Hyperlipideme bekannt.
Deswegen nehmen wir regelmäßig folgende Medikamente ein.
Amnobitin 5 mg einmal, Atrovasitinin 20 mg einmal,
etroxin 5 mg einmal,
es ist bei einem Ton sindektome, als Kindheit.
Er ist in der Kinder.
Er ist in der Familie in Nanamnese, ist es arbeinenswurst,
dass seine Mutter an Apokalyse gestorben ist und sein Vater
ist Einzelkind.
Er hat arbeinenswurst, als Maschin-Wau-Engineer
bei einer Büro.
Er ist verheiratet und hat ein Tochter.
Er hat viel in den Farat.
Er fühlt sich fibrisch.
Wenn ein Präxigibt kommt,
eine Infektion in Frage.
Ich werde digitale Rektaluntersuchung durchführen.
Ich werde eine Rektale Fibromessung
beider Artikulitis
beider Artikulitis.
Ich werde eine Rektale Fibromessung
beider Artikulitis
beider Artikulitis.
Ich werde eine Rektale Fibromessung
Wenn es Komplikationen gibt, vielleicht werde ich eine Philosophie im Bauchbereich,
nicht im Douglas-Berach.
Douglas.
Douglas-Berach erwarten.
Vielleicht zum Ausschluss, nieren, schütteln,
Harnwachs Impact, da würde ich ja Harnleiter und Renage-Schütterung betrachten,
ob es eine Erwartung oder Schütteln gibt.
Und, ja, ich...
Wann waren die letzten, wann waren die letzten Wärmspielungen von den Patienten?
Er hat 51 Jahre alt.
Ich habe gefragt, vorherige Behandlungen, er hat aber nicht erwähnt.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Ja.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er eine Wärmspielung hat?
Ich habe nicht zielgerischte gefragt, ich habe generalgefragt.
Ja, sollen Sie trotzdem fragen, ob er schon eine Wärmspielung hatte bei Ihrer Verdachtsdiagnose?
Müssen Sie fragen, haben Sie die Vorsorgeuntersuchung machen lassen?
Er ist ja schon über 50 Jahre alt, hat er schon eine Wärmspielung gehabt,
war ja beim Urologen, hat er die Poste dazchecken lassen.
Also Vorsorgeuntersuchung sollte man ab 50 immer fragen.
Ja, ich habe mir auch gedacht, er ist begrenzt alter für Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Aber vielleicht habt ihr ja schon mal etwas gehabt und vielleicht habt ihr einen Haushalts-
Vor fünf Jahren zur Kontrolle lässt es mal beim Haushalts-
Deswegen, ich möchte nicht Zeit für eine Verluste.
Und trotzdem kann man fragen.
Ich habe recht, ich musste fragen.
Trotzdem kann man fragen.
Was machen Sie denn außer Ultraschall auf der Bildgebung?
Wenn Sie Ultraschall nicht sehen, Sie sehen in Ultraschall,
sehen Sie nichts wegen schlechten Schallbedingungen.
Aber er hat Entzündungswerte, was machen Sie denn?
Ich habe mich beurteilen.
Und nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf oder lassen Sie den in einer Ambulanz?
Ja, natürlich.
Wovon machen Sie das abhängig?
Ob Sie den Patienten stationär aufnehmen oder nicht?
Ich habe eine Akute-Nattfall.
Ich habe eine komplikation aufgenommen.
Deswegen habe ich die Stationärbehandlung aufgenommen.
Ich habe eine große Überwachung.
Ich werde eine Zuganglegen, eine Flüssigkeit einleiten.
Ich beginne mit der Nahrungskarrenz.
Ich werde eine Antibioterapie verappreischen.
Ich gebe die Antibioterapie.
Welche Antibioterapie?
Bei der Diwert-Kylitis,
mögliche Erreger, Gramm-negative Bakterien.
Deswegen würde ich Scherectegeneration, Sephalosporin,
und gegebenenfalls SIPRO, Fluoro-Kinolone,
Grupo Antibiotika verappreischen.
Und gegen Antigen an Aerobika Bakterien,
plus Metronen,
würde ich verappreischen.
Wenn Sie keine Entschuldungswerte im Labor sehen,
was machen Sie dann?
Vielleicht eine SIP-Werte.
Ich werde kontrollieren,
die Urinprobewerte.
Er hat Brennende Schmerz.
Deswegen würde ich eine Herz-Weg-Impact auszulesen.
Sie haben jetzt Urines Unaufwärts- und Blut.
Er hat keine Leukocytose, kein CRP.
Was machen Sie dann?
Geben Sie trotzdem Antibiotika?
Es ist nicht erforderlich.
Ich kann auch Analgetika geben.
Was würden Sie geben, Analgetika?
Ich werde nicht zytheroidal Antiromatismus.
Ich würde die Klopfenack,
die Klopfenack, die Klopfenack, die Klopfenack.
Die Klopfenack? Mir nicht bekannt.
Mir nicht bekannt. Also es gibt mir nicht bekannt, dass wir hier Ibuprofen oder die Klopfenack über die Wehne geben.
Man gibt meistens über die Wehne Novemberminusulfon oder man gibt ein Opioidpräparat,
Petidin zum Beispiel, so etwas hart.
Können Sie überlegen, ob Sie das machen?
Dann können Sie noch ein bisschen Buske panen geben.
Können Sie auch machen, aber normalerweise ist die erste Wahl auch nicht direkt NSR.
Das ist nicht die erste Wahl an Schmerzmedikamenten im Krankenhaus.
Das kann man, können Sie vielleicht ambulant probieren.
Aber muss man gucken.
Ich würde nicht immer empfohlen.
In der Türkei machen wir von...
Aber wir sind hier in Deutschland.
Wir sind aber hier in Deutschland.
Was Sie in der Türkei machen, ist egal.
Wenn Sie jetzt keine erhöhten Infektwert haben, nehmen Sie den Patienten trotzdem stationär auf
oder lassen Sie wieder nach Hause gehen?
Ach, geben Sie mir Schmerzmedikamenten hier im Maden.
Ich werde die Patienten ein paar Stunden in der Nachtaufnahme
bis die Abheilung von Bescheverden.
Danach vielleicht kann ich zu Hause lassen.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Haushalt?
Wenn Sie eine Bericht schreiben, was empfehlen Sie dem Haushalt?
Was soll der Haushalt mit den Patienten machen, wenn Sie ihn nach Hause lassen?
Ich empfehle dem Haushalt, dass die Patienten nach Gastroenterologen überwiesen,
ob eine Gewerkschulistik ausschließen.
Aber dann kommt ein Termin erst in vier, fünf Monaten.
Das dauert lange, bis man ein Termin bekommt.
Was Sie machen können, Sie können dem, wenn der Patient nichts zum Blut hat,
die Beschwerden werden besser können.
Sie haben einen Ultraschall gemacht und Sie haben einen CT gemacht.
Haben Sie gemacht, ist alles unauffällig, aber Sie haben Gott sei Dank nichts gefunden,
nichts Relevantes.
Dann können Sie dem Patienten sagen, Sie können ihm ein Termin mitgeben,
eine Ambulanz, der kann sich bei uns in der Krankenhaus vorstellen.
Sie müssen ihn nicht stationär aufnehmen, Sie können in meinen ambulanten Termin
keine Darmspilung geben.
Aber ich würde den tatsächlich einen Tag überwachen.
Vielleicht muss man auch mal eine Stuhlprobe kontrollieren, haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Einmal die Stuhlprobe wechseln, ob er etwas, ob er zum Beispiel,
man könnte Kalbprotektin bestimmen im Stuhl.
Das sind diese Entzündungswerte, die in Darms sind.
Ob der Pathogenekaim hat, das würde ich auch kontrollieren.
Ich würde ihn schon einen Tag da lassen und einmal überwachen.
Wenn der Patient beschwerdefreies gehen möchte,
dann kann man ihn noch gehen lassen.
Aber Stuhlprobe ist definitiv wichtig, weil er hat ja schon anscheinend auch
Durchfall, haben Sie erzählt.
Das würde ich schon machen, auch wenn es jetzt nicht länger als eine
halbe Woche sind, würde ich trotzdem einmal die Entzündungszeichen,
insbesondere das Kalbprobektin, im Stuhl einmal nachschauen, ob das erhöht sein
könnte oder nicht.
Und Pathogenekaim machen.
Ansonsten, wenn Sie keine Kapazitäten haben, Sie haben
freie Betten, können Sie ihn auch aufnehmen und die Darmspilung am
nächsten Tag machen, wenn er keine Entzündungszeichen hat,
nach abführenden Maßnahmen.
Aber wichtig ist, wie Sie gesagt haben, Blutabnahme, Ultraschall
und CT.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Danke schön.
Sehr gut.
Gibt es noch Fragen für den Patienten?
Alles klar, gibt es Unklarheiten?
Irgendwas, was Sie interessiert, was besprochen werden sollte,
was vielleicht anders ist, als in der Türkei und hier.
Ein Differenzialdiagnose, haben Sie ja schon gesagt,
könnte eine Qualität sein.
Welche Qualitäten denken Sie hier zum Beispiel?
Was könnte es sein, was im Alter auch auftreten kann noch?
Etampolitis.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Es kann Etampolitis sein, es kann aber auch eine chronisch
entzündliche Damerkrankung sein.
Es könnte vielleicht ein Kron sein, ob es Kron sagt,
ob es Kron sagt, kondensatorosa, vielleicht nicht,
das macht sich meistens eher mit Blut im Stuhl bemerkbar.
Es könnte eine ganze Male Gastroenteritis sein,
könnte auch sein.
Krebs sein, es könnte Krebs sein, es könnte auch ein Appendicitis sein,
könnte auch sein, das könnte sein,
das auch sein könnte.
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten.
Bei Frauen kann es auch zum Beispiel so etwas sein,
in dem Alter vielleicht nicht mehr, aber also Appnicitis
und Variant zwischen Ruptur, so etwas in der Art.
Man muss man einmal daran denken.
Wenn er jetzt eine Divertikolose,
Sie haben sagen wir mal, Sie haben den Patienten ausgenommen,
er hat jetzt eine akute Divertikolitis
und Sie haben ihn stationär behandelt.
Wir gehen jetzt nicht auf die Stadien von Divertikolitis,
es gibt ja 1A, 1CB und so weiter,
dann geht es weiter, das können Sie nochmal nachlesen.
Und Sie haben den Patienten jetzt wieder nach Hause entlasten,
nachdem Sie ihn anthribiologisch behandelt haben.
Sie würden ja bei ihm keine,
Sie haben das im CT bemerkt,
Sie würden aber keine Darmspiegel machen, richtig?
Wenn er eine akute Infektion hat,
würden Sie trotzdem eine Darmspiegel machen oder nicht?
Eine Kolonoskopie ist kontränisiert.
Bei der Akute Divertikolitis attacken.
Dann empfehlen Sie ihm,
Sie empfehlen ihm im Verlauf
eine ambulante Darmspiegelung zu machen,
nach Abkennen der Infektion.
Und wenn man jetzt eine Divertikolose hat,
bekannt, was empfiehlt man den Patienten so,
damit es nicht wieder zu einer Divertikolitis kommt,
gibt es Empfehlungen, die man aussprechen kann, den Patienten?
Ich werde ein Einungsberater,
die eine Risikofaktur
und gesünder Ernährung.
Der raucht ja auch, und ist auch ein Bluthochdruck.
Genau, er sollte belaststoffreich Ernährung machen,
wobei das wieder auch momentan im Gespräch ist,
viel Wasser trinken,
so was er noch hat.
Können Sie ja nochmal durchlesen einmal.
Ist denn eine Divertikolose heilbar?
Kann man die heilen?
Bilden sich die Divertikolose wieder zurück?
Das ist nicht heilbare Krankheit.
Man sollte von Attacke,
von Divertikolitis vermeiden,
um die Massnahmen einzuhalten.
Und wenn er jetzt immer wieder eine Divertikolitis hat,
dann ist das so alle zwei Jahre, zum Beispiel immer wieder.
Was würden Sie dann empfehlen?
Eine Kollektor, mehr viel Last content.
Ein operatives Verfahren.
Sehr gut.
Dann noch viel Spaß mit dem Patienten gleich.